10.
9.
8.
7.
(TOGETHER) 6, 5, 4, 3, 2, 1.
Ghostwriter, Beyond the Page.
Hi.
Here we are ready to go for episode 4 of Ghostwriter,
Beyond the Page.
So far Donna has gotten lots of very helpful hints
from Ghostwriter to help her create her story.
She's come up with an interesting character,
unique settings, and some key plot points.
It's time for her to put it all together.
For the first time her story is going to come to life.
It's alive!
Not that much different from the challenge
that the doctor faced in Frankenstein
as he had to deal with his creation.
So let's see how Donna deals with her creation
as she works to finish her book.
Let's see.
Welcome to Donna's Video Diary.
Sapphire's adventure is really coming together.
To try to get her friends to see her talent for sewing
and fashion the same way that they appreciate her brother's
athletics, Sapphire decides what better way to show off her work
than with a fashion show.
Perfect, right?
But that's when the obstacles come in
to create more conflict.
Spelman has a soccer game scheduled
at the exact same time as Sapphire's show.
And their friends have to decide which one to go to.
Plus, two of Sapphire's models are on the soccer team.
So she has to come up with a solution fast.
And on top of all of that, the humans
sweep out the entire fashion section of the store,
destroying all of Sapphire's designs.
So much drama, I'm loving this.
Don't worry, though.
In the end, Spelman sees Sapphire's new designs
and is really impressed.
He tells his sister.
And with Spelman on her side, she spins up a whole new plan.
She convinces the coach to let her put
on the show in halftime right in the middle of the field.
It's a totally fashion-forward, spectacular halftime show.
And Spelman even volunteers to be one of the models.
The crowd goes wild.
Sapphire's designs are a showstopper.
They're the talk of the bookstore bugs.
They even want her to design the new uniforms for the team.
Her hard work and creativity really pay off.
You know, it feels like I practically just started.
And now I almost have all the pieces
ready to actually put together my story.
I almost don't want to reach the finish line.
It's like reaching the final chapter
of a book I never want to end.
But Ghostwriter hasn't sent anything new yet,
so maybe I should just focus more on the pieces
that I already have.
I could spend more time creating some more characters,
or get more detailed with the setting
before I just dive right into actually writing them
into the story.
Create.
Create on every page.
Ghostwriter is really trying to make a point with this one.
It's not hard to see that GW wants
me to get writing and finish creating my story.
There's got to be another step first, right?
I mean, what about coming up with more bullet points?
I just am not ready to finish and create.
Donna, my, what a wonderful surprise.
It's nice to see you, too, Dr. Frankenstein.
Your visit is well-timed.
I'm just finishing packing up some things.
Traveling soon.
Oh, well, I'm glad I didn't miss you.
Actually, I was wondering if I could ask you something.
Of course.
I'm happy to offer any insight I can.
Well, you see, I've started this project,
and I'm really close to finishing it.
I've got all the pieces ready.
And I just need to put them together.
But I'm not sure if I feel ready for it to come to an end.
I mean, you wish you had waited and really thought things
through before you put together Bob, or, I mean, the monster.
Well, the truth is, at first, I did
wish I had not been so eager to finish creating my monster.
Oh.
Well, what do you wish now?
What I truly wish, looking back, is
that I'd followed through with my experiment to the very end,
that I taught him skills, and compassion, and shown him love.
If I had seen my experiment through,
then when he went out into the world,
he could have had a truly good life.
Well, that's not exactly the answer I was expecting.
But I know you must be right.
Bob did have a lot of potential to be good,
if only he was given a chance.
Exactly.
Donna, I know sometimes we can get in our own way
as we approach the final moment of things we don't want to end.
But I do hope that you follow through
and finish your project.
Who can say what wonders you may be able to create if you never
finish them?
You're right, Dr. Frankenstein.
I might never feel ready to come to the end of this journey
and see what comes next, but I won't know
until I cross the finish line.
Thanks for all your help.
It has been a pleasure seeing you again, Donna.
And I anticipate great things from you and your project.
Dr. Frankenstein is right.
I'll never get to see where my story could go
if I never take the final step.
Hey, I bet there's a good chapter in Frankenstein
to help me out.
My story is long, and you must be cold," the monster said.
He invited me to sit and pulled branches off a nearby tree
to start a small fire.
"I hardly remember the night I came to life," he said.
"People on the street screamed when they saw me.
Some tried to attack.
Many threw things at me."
"I quickly learned to hide my face and avoid humans.
Then I got hungry.
I found food in a shop window.
The glass was easy to break.
I didn't know why angry voices chased me.
I ran far away from the city and into the forest.
Finally I came to a cottage with a small woodshed.
I curled up to sleep behind a pile of firewood."
"I awoke to voices," the creature continued.
"It was morning.
The family who lived in the cottage was waking up.
I wanted to run away, but I heard them speaking.
Their voices were cheerful and pleasant.
They sounded completely different
from all the angry voices I had heard in my short life."
"What did the family do when they saw you?"
I asked.
"They didn't.
I stayed out of sight."
The monster nodded.
"The cottage was home to a very old man
and his teenage grandson and granddaughter.
They were a poor but loving family.
I stole food from their garden and slept in their woodshed
without being caught.
I lived this way for weeks," the monster said,
"until I started to notice how the family always did things
for each other.
They made each other happier by helping.
And when they were happy, it made me happy.
So, in secret, I did chores to help them.
I only did small things.
I refilled their woodshed, and kept wild animals away
from their house and garden.
I tried to make their lives easier without having
them realize I was there."
I was glad to hear that the monster had done a good deed.
My heart twinged with a strange feeling.
Was it pride?
If Dr. Frankenstein had just helped the monster
and followed through instead of avoiding him,
the monster could have had a better life,
and maybe even taught the doctor something new along the way.
I'm ready for what comes next.
In fact, I'm really excited.
I know that I have to finish creating this adventure
to start the new one.
And hey, maybe I'll even share my story with my friends
and family when it's done.
When one chapter ends, the next one begins.
Now, if you want to dive deeper into the Ghostwriter world,
be sure to read Frankenstein, and go
to the Franken-Ghost section of the activity guide.
And of course, check in with the Ghostwriter gang on Apple TV+
to watch episodes of the show.
So until we meet again, keep on writing, keep on creating,
and keep on sharing.
Bye now.